now that schools are taking your tax
money and not even opening their doors
to students this could be a breakthrough
moment for the school choice movement
let's talk about that now with director
of school choice at the reason
foundation
corey d'angelos cory look i don't want
to talk about the principle we all agree
school choice great you know i've been
fighting for it
what i'm interested in hearing from you
is some sense of the options that are
there
it's not just charter schools provided
by local
uh enabled by local governments
innovation and
entrepreneurial activity is really
giving parents lots of new and different
options can you tell us about some of
them
yeah thank you so much for having me
steve and i just want to point out that
families have been getting the short end
of the stick when it comes to k-12
education for far too long and like you
said
the lockdown situation and the school
reopening debate has really made that
clear
now more than ever because families are
essentially powerless and the way to fix
that is to fund families directly
just like we do with a whole host of
other taxpayer-funded initiatives
whether that comes
to pell grants at the higher education
level gi bill at the higher education
level pre-k
programs also that deals with education
and food stamps the money goes directly
to families
and families can pick different
providers of the service and so we
should do the exact same thing when it
comes to
k-12 education and if you like we can
even call it something like u-b-e-i
universal basic education income have
the funding go to the families
and we should fund students instead of
school systems just like we do with all
these other programs
and like you ask there's a whole host of
different options besides
charter schools there are magnet schools
there are virtual charter schools which
you were talking about
with jordan sekulow before when the
families were being blocked in oregon
other states were blocking families from
from switching to charter schools as
well such as california
and pennsylvania so we may see lawsuits
in other states like that as well but
there are also voucher programs where
the funding again goes to the family in
the form of the voucher and they can
take it to a private school of their
choosing
or even uh something like a micro school
which gets into this
conversation about education scholarship
accounts or education savings accounts
which is again
it's kind of like the voucher idea but
the funding goes to the family and you
can use it for these tutoring services
online providers and there already have
been families getting together
uh in large numbers across the united
states washington post just wrote about
it a couple of days ago
where families are getting together in
groups of like 10 you know five to ten
students in one household
and they're essentially outsourcing the
process of homeschooling and this is
called micro schools
so i i would recommend looking at micro
schools or home school co-ops in your
area to check this out and just
just think about it for a second we
spend over fifteen thousand dollars per
child per year
in the united states uh in public
schools just imagine if that funding
went to families directly and you got 10
students together in a household
that's over 15 150 000
in total revenues coming in just imagine
if only you know a third of that went to
overhead cost
the teacher would still have around a
hundred thousand dollars left over
and look so this this option could
benefit teachers a lot if they're in
high demand
and it can benefit families and students
as well to to get these options as well
and i will say
uh this would benefit the least
advantage more than anyone else because
there are already very advantaged
families going around in the u.s
forming these groups it's the least
advantaged families who are having
trouble finding these options
and so again we should fund these
families directly and allow them to
to find these options so that everybody
can have educational options uh not just
the most advantaged in society
well look at that you're so good at this
cory i was literally
you answered all the questions that i
was gonna put to you thank you so much i
think we should make you education
secretary that was absolutely fantastic
love the conversation about micro
schools a sort of twist on homeschooling
people should look that up it's
really really interesting cory we'll
stay in touch as our campaign
moves forward for the moment thank you
very much i want to bring back kim
and steve on this kim i just think and
you heard that whole conversation
my call for you know getting people
getting their money back if this if this
if they're not getting uh what they want
in terms of the school district
opening schools all these innovative
options entrepreneurialism providing
new opportunities for parents to deliver
the education for their children that
they want in different ways
i think it's a really exciting moment
potentially
oh i think it's enormous uh because it's
pushing everything to the fore and let
me point out who's really pushing it to
the fore it's the unions
you know i mean these are people that
are not only refusing to educate our
children but setting up
incredibly high hurdles in order to
agree to go back to school and even
demanding things like
the la teachers union which this week
said it wouldn't go back to school
unless it got
medicare for all and another federal
bailout and an end
to charter schools okay and so
and now you have governor gavin newsom
in california
saying that even the private schools
can't reopen that's a protection for
teachers unions because
he knew that some parents were beginning
to look at these options because those
schools were going to open
what i would love to see steve in our
that we are going to have another
federal
uh coronavirus bill i would like to see
some
standards and and rules put into it
about how the money that has already
gone out to states can be used
and and make clear that it can't be used
by any districts that are not opening
and educating kids
very good steve your thoughts on how
this
could actually accelerate something that
we've all been um advocating for for
many years the whole school choice
movement
so you started asking uh kim at the
start of the show
what could president trump do
unilaterally to get this economy moving
how about this idea steve and i know
president trump watches your show
mr president give every single parent
in a district where the schools are not
going to open up where the government
said we're not opening up the schools i
live in one of them
give every parent a ten thousand dollar
federal voucher
we spend 50 billion dollars at the
federal level and let the parents
go to schools if the other schools we
have in my neighborhood
exactly what you guys were just talking
about where four or five parents are
getting together
they're gonna teach the kids why not let
let the money go to the parents in these
schools so that our kids
get a decent education this fall i love
it this is so exciting because
the whole voucher thing the thing that
that's why i did the my school money
back thing because
it's frustrating because although we're
all in favor of it you kind of have to
wait for your local government your
local authority to decide to do the
vouchers and get this is like the
grassroots pressure from below but
you're right
the president can do it from the
oval office so let's see that very
exciting